>> Sean: THE MEDIA'S HATRED
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ONCE
AGAIN ON FULL DISPLAY.
LISTEN DO THIS.
ANYMORE.
REALITY TV APPEARANCES.
TABLOID GOSSIP.
CONSPIRACY THEORIES,
NAME-CALLING, VULGARITY AND
A LEVEL OF EGOMANIA PEOPLE
HAVE NEVER SEEN IN
WASHINGTON.
THAT'S SAYING SOMETHING.
LIKE WE ARE LIVING INSIDE A
PARODY FROM THREE YEARS AGO.
CONSIDER WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
IF DONALD TRUMP.
REALITY SHOW.
HE TWEETS LIKE IT'S A
>> BY THE WAY CHUCK TODD, HE
CLAIMS TO BE A HARD NEWSED
UNBIASED OBJECTIVE
JOURNALIST.
REACTED TO PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
IDEA OF HAVING A MILITARY
PARADE.
LET'S SEE.
HOLLYWOOD.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
INSANITY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
TRUMP WANTS A MILITARY
PARADE.
SO YOU ARE JUST GOING FULL
DICTATOR NOW?
JUST [BLEEP] WASN'T ENOUGH.
>> I GUESS HE WANTS HIS TOY
SOLDIERS TO MARCH IN FRONT
OF HIM IN LINE IN LOCK STEP.
>> SOME SAID IT WOULD PUT US
LOVE A MILITARY PARADE.
>> THE IDEA THAT WE HAVE TO
MAYBE THE ANTIDOTE IS TO
JUST GET DONALD TRUMP A
MILITARY UNIFORM WITH ON THE
SHOULDERS AND GIVE HIM SOME
SALAD DRESSING TO PUT ON THE
LEFT LAPEL AND LET HIM MARCH
AROUND.
>> Sean: I SAID IT BEFORE I
WILL SAY IT AGAIN.
THE LEFT WING DESTROY MEDIA
HERE NOW IS SHOWERS
HERE NOW IS SEAWERS
HERE NOW IS SEANERS
HERE NOW IS SEAN SS
HERE NOW IS SEAN SPICER AND
THE HILL'S JOE CONCHA.
YOU GO BACK AND SEE THIS
WOULDN'T BE THE FIRST TIME,
SEAN, OH, FDR, THE BELOVED
FDR HAD THIS HAPPEN AND
EISENHOWER HAD SOMETHING
SIMILAR AND LET'S SEE, JFK,
NOT A FULL DISPLAY BUT THEY
HAD THEIR OWN DISPLAYS.
AND THEN I THINK OF EVERY
HOLLYWOOD AWARD CEREMONY,
EVERY MUSIC CEREMONY BUT WE
CAN'T HAVE AN HONORING
PARADE OF THE MILITARY?
REALLY?
WHY IS THAT SO HARD?
ONE, EVERYONE JUMPED TO THE
IMMEDIATE CONCLUSION OF
ASSOCIATING WITH A DICTATOR
AS OPPOSED TO SOMEBODY WHO
LOVES AND RESPECTS THE
MILITARY AND'S TO HONOR THEM
FOR THEIR SERVICE.
IT'S AMAZING.
MAYBE I'M WRONG.
I ABOIL GUISE IF I AM.
I DON'T THINK A SINGLE ONE
OF THEM HAS EVER SERVED.
FUNNY WHETHER YOU HAVE A
PRESIDENT WHO RESPECTS AND
HONORS LAW ENFORCEMENT,
FIRST RESPONDERS AND THE
MILITARY AND SAYS I WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE A PARADE TO
SHOWCASE THEM TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THAT'S
SOMEHOW A NEGATIVE THING?
LESS THAN 1% OF THE PEOPLE
HAVE SERVED IN THE MILITARY
THESE DAYS.
THOSE DEPLOYED EVERY DAY TO
PROTECT OUR FREEDOM.
WHEN YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT
WHO WANTS TO HONOR THEM AND
SHOW THE RESPECT THAT THEY
DESERVE AND MAYBE MAKE THEM
ABLE TO MEET SOMEONE WHO HAS
SERVED BEFORE, I THINK
THAT'S A POSITIVE THING FOR
OUR COUNTRY.
AND TO SEE SOME MEMBERS OF
THE MEDIA IMMEDIATELY JUMP
TO NEGATIVE CONCLUSIONS.
>> Sean: UNBELIEVABLE.
>> SHOWS HOW DISCONNECTED
THEY ARE TO THE NOT ONLY THE
MILITARY BUT WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THIS COUNTRY.
AN END.
I THINK I SAW THAT IN
GLADIATOR.
>> HOLD ON, SEAN, IN
CONTRAST, WHEN THE PRESIDENT
TRAGEDY.
HE WAS DISRESPECTING THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
OH, IT WAS THE END OF THE
EARTH, THE APOCALYPSE WAS
COMING.
WHEN HE WANTS TO HAVE A
PARADE TO HONOR THE
MILITARY, OH BY GOD THAT'S
HORRIBLE.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, YOU THINK
ABOUT IT, I ADDED UP, IT WAS
SOMETHING LIKE 25, 30,
BETWEEN THE MUSIC INDUSTRY
AND THE ACADEMY AWARDS, THE
GLOBAL AWARDS, THIS AWARDS,
JOE CONCHA, I THINK IT'S
ACTUALLY A GREAT IDEA.
AND I THINK THE COUNTRY, WE
OWE THEM A DEBT OF GRATITUDE
AND ANY WAY TO HONOR THEM I
THINK IS WELL WORTH IT.
>> I THINK BECAUSE PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S NAME IS INVOLVED IN
THIS PROPOSAL, SEAN, THAT
THAT IS CAUSING THE
REACTION.
AND YOU CAN PLAY A GAME OF
WHAT IF CHUCK SCHUMER HAD
ACTUALLY PROPOSED A
MILITARY -- OH, THAT'S
AND THERE WASN'T A SNIFF OF
YOU CAN HONOR THE MILITARY
WITH A PARADE.
NO PROBLEM.
THE COSTS ARE DOWN.
LOGISTICALLY PULL IT OFF.
NO PROBLEM.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT COULD
REALLY BACK UP THOSE WORDS
AND BACK UP A PARADE BY
HE HASN'T DONE THAT YET.
I THINK THAT WILL GO A LONG
WAY IN SHOWING HE IS NOT
>> Sean: EVEN IF HE DOES
THAT I'M SURE IT WILL BE
CRITICIZED.
HOW DID THEY MISS THE
BIGGEST STORY IN THEIR
LIFETIME CO-CONCHA?
>> HAVE THEY GOT IT WRONG.
THE EVIDENCE IS STILL GOING.
>> Sean: IS THERE ANY
EVIDENCE OVER THE YEAR THAT
YOU SEE.
REMEMBER, EVERYTHING GETS
LEAKS THESE DAYS.
IF THEY DID HAVE SOMETHING,
POST" OR THE "NEW YORK
TIMES."
NOT YET.
LET MUELLER FINISH HIS
INVESTIGATION BEFORE WE
>> Sean: I DON'T THINK
MUELLER SHOULD HAVE BEEN
THERE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
MEMO AND UNREDACTED GRASSILY
GRAHAM MEMO, SEAN SPICER,
SEEMS TO ME THIS WHOLE THING
WAS A WITCH PUNT FROM THE
I WANT THE INVESTIGATION TO
BEEN VERY CLEAR FRUFT
BEGINNING THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION.
AT SOME POINT YOU RUN OUT
THE CLOCK AND YOU SAY AS
HAVE YOU NOTED THAT IF YOU
HAVEN'T FOUND ANYTHING BY
NOW, LET'S GIVE IT A BREAK.
THE STUFF THEY FOUND PEOPLE
FOR IN TERMS OF LYING TO
THEM AND FARA ARE OBVIOUSLY
VIOLATIONS OF THE LAW AND
THOSE PEOPLE SHOULD BE
PROSECUTED.
THE UNDERLYING PREMISE OF
THIS WHOLE THING COLLUSION
FROM RUSSIA AS YOU POINTED
OUT AND JOE CORROBORATED,
THERE HAS BEEN NOTHING SO
FAR.
WE LET THIS PLAY OUT.
BUT I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
INTERESTING TO SEE WHERE THE
PRESS GOES FROM THERE.
BECAUSE THEY WERE WRONG
ABOUT THE ELECTION.
THEY WERE SO READY TO
CORONATE HILLARY CLINTON
THEY WERE ALL CRYING
ELECTION NIGHT.
NOW THAT THEY HAVE WRAPPED
THEMSELVES AROUND THIS AXLE
WE WILL SEE WHERE THEY GO
FROM THERE.
WILL THEY ADMIT THEY WERE
TRUMP OR MOVE ONTO THE NEXT
ONE?
I HAVE A FEELING THAT'S WHAT
WILL HAPPEN.
>> Sean: HOW DID THEY MISS
THE BULK OF THE FISA WARRANT
WAS PAID FOR BILL LIES.
>> SOMETIMES THERE IS BIAS
WHERE IT'S OUT IN THE ONLY
AND CLEAR A REPORTER OR
THEN THERE IS ANOTHER KIND
OF BIAS AND SEAN KNOWS ALL
I MEAN, WHEN SEAN WAS PRESS
SECRETARY, I'M SURE HE WAS
JUST STUNNED AT THE
QUESTIONS THAT WEREN'T ASKED
ON RUSSIA.
YEAH, I THINK THAT'S A BIG
STORY THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
COVERED BECAUSE THEY DON'T
LIKE THE NARRATIVE.